además de estos dos tiroteos que se han
reportado en medios nacionales según con
control art aids en eeuu se han
reportado el 24 de marzo 104 tiroteos
masivos en el país donde han muerto 4
mil 171 personas yo bailé en además de
lamentar este reciente tiroteo en el
boulder colorado donde murieron 10
personas le pidió al congreso que
apruebe dos leyes para la revisión de
antecedentes de los estadounidenses que
quieran adquirir un arma y también le
pidió al congreso que apruebe una ley
para restringir definitivamente la
compra y el uso de rifles
semiautomáticos son los rifles
precisamente ar-15 los semi automáticos
los que se han usado en los recientes
tiroteos masivos que han causado la
muerte de miles de estadounidenses joe
biden también dijo que iba a apoyar
estas medidas de ser aprobadas por el
congreso con órdenes ejecutivas llama la
atención sin embargo que en
la lista de órdenes ejecutivas que el
presidente joe biden ha tratado de
impulsar desde que llegó a la casa
blanca no se incluye ninguna orden
ejecutiva dirigida al control de armas
lo que están diciendo varios analistas
acá es que a pesar de que la cámara de
representantes ya aprobó estas medidas
que sugiere yo bailén de hechos las
aprobó precisamente porque son la cámara
representantes tiene la mayoría
demócrata- pues tiene la barrera de
pasarse y de aprobarse en el senado los
analistas dicen que una vez llegue al
senado esta ley estas leyes contra el
control para para el control de armas en
eeuu se hundirá como se ha hundido en
los últimos diez años en la cámara alta